every year people spend about eight
point five billion dollars on treatments
for hair loss
it's an incredible figure and it speaks
to how deeply people are affected by it
and how badly did like for them to be a
cure but the thing is there's no
treatment that actually regrows large
amounts of hair
a new treatment for baldness maybe I'm
worried well I'm interested in the
subject obviously the drug was applied
regularly and new hair began to sprout a
cure for baldness might be the most
perpetually delayed of all the medical
advances we're told are just around the
corner
now there are a few perspective
treatments that are very promising and
we can get to those in a minute but
first it's good to examine why exactly
hair is such a tricky problem and how
overtime hype has often played a bigger
role than science and getting people's
hopes up for a cure
so the first thing is hair itself is
pretty simple it's just dead cells stuff
for the protein but the follicles that
make hair are incredibly complex they're
technically an organ like your heart or
your kidneys they're very specialized
structures that form early in your
development and they can never be
regrown by the 22nd week a fetus already
has all five million of the hair
follicles that'll ever produce and the
hair that these follicles make can
change like how it gets thicker and
darker during puberty but you can never
grow new follicles now in terms of
treatments even back in the 1950s 60s
and 70s when we didn't know very much
about how hair worked cures for baldness
were still promised and they were I mean
mostly totally ridiculous 50 Guinness
for 15 grams hide some of the baldness
and does it it does experiments carried
out on monkeys are said to be
encouraging testosterone injections or
have steroids rubbed on your scalp you
could have electric shocks or vacuuming
on the skin where the hair was supposed
to grow there was even a Japanese
pharmaceutical company that marketed a
CD of music that was supposed to promote
hair growth there were so many
fraudulent cures that in the mid-1980s
the American Food and Drug
Administration actually banned any
medication that claimed to treat hair
loss
now some real treatments were actually
found towards the end of the 1980s but
the thing was they came about almost
entirely by accident
experiments which may produce the
world's first real baldness cure it
happened by accident doctors
administering a new drug for treating
patients with high blood pressure found
interesting side effects a side effect
of that medication was it grew hair on
people it was a nuisance
it grew bushy eyebrows and heavy body
here and then a drug for enlarged
prostate
called finasteride was shown to slow
down or halt hair loss in some people
the drugs didn't actually regrow full
heads of hair and they didn't work for
everybody but they were incredibly big
news at the time the media referred to
them as cures and I think people thought
that they were the first step in a new
era of successful treatments the problem
was that they didn't follow from any big
revelation in medical science basically
we have a treatment for a process that
we don't fully understand and incredibly
in the last thirty years those are the
only two drugs that have ever been
approved for hair loss since the 1990s
even though we haven't found any new
drugs we've learned a lot about how hair
actually works it turns out that unlike
other organs hair follicles are kind of
constantly remodeling themselves
changing structure depending on whether
they're growing hair shedding hair
arresting and they use stem cells to do
this it's sort of like they're
constantly in development and they do
use a lot of the same pathways and
signals that are used in early human
development there's a biotech company
run by a Turkish American billionaire
that has a very secretive drug that
works on one of these pathways that's
currently in human trials they say that
it can regrow hair and there are several
Japanese research groups that say that
they can clone your hair follicles grow
them up in a dish and manipulate their
signaling to grow new hair and then
presumably transplant it back on your
head and their work is also in human
drops all of these discoveries have
launched massive new projects that make
better scientific sense than previous
treatments but they're often in fields
that are relatively new and quite
complex themselves and stem cells are
historically quite overhyped and there's
still a lot we don't know but the
science behind hair loss itself so well
a cure looks more realistic than at any
time in the recent past expectations are
probably still way too high
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon